أجنبي
[موسيقى]
كم من كل هذا حقيقي وكم
منه تقليدي وكم من
الناس يعيشون بالفعل هذا النوع من الحياة
اليوم تتمتع منغوليا بهذا التراث الثقافي الغني بشكل لا يصدق
[موسيقى]
هذه هي معجناتنا
لذلك تأكلها  معجنات مع الأوروم
وهي كريمة متخثرة أوه أوه، جربها إنه أمر
لا يصدق، إنها طازجة وجديدة، يفعلون
ذلك كل يوم في الصباح،
لا، هذا جيد، صحيح
[موسيقى]
بالطبع يمكنك أن يكون لديك مجموعة من الأشخاص
الذين سيؤدون الرقص التقليدي
و  هذه هي الطريقة التي اعتادوا أن يفعلوا بها
هذا والآخر ولكن كيف يمكنك
بالفعل الحفاظ على أسلوب الحياة الذي يعتبر
بلدًا إلى حد ما أسلوب الحياة الحديث
بالطبع يمثل تحديًا بالنسبة لنا ليس فقط
لمنغوليا للعالم ولكن أيضًا
المهرجانات الثقافية البدوية  مثل هذا هو
حقًا إظهار ثقافتنا للعالم
ومشاركة الثقافة مع العالم الذي
في المقابل يحافظ على ثقافتنا ويحميها،
ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالحياة الثقافية نفسها، كان لدينا دائمًا
أسلوب الحياة البدوي بأنفسنا ومن ثم فهو جزء
من حياتنا اليوم.
تقليد حي مستمر وأعتقد
أنه سيستمر لأجيال طويلة. كنت
أنظر إلى
الرعاة وهم يقومون بجميع
الاحتفالات التقليدية المتمثلة في التعامل مع الجبن
وتذوق الحليب ثم الخروج  يأتي
الهاتف لأنه من الواضح أنهم ما
زالوا يعيشون حياة عصرية ولكن إلى متى
يمكن لهذا النوع من الحياة أن يتحرك لمسافة
مائة كيلومتر أربع مرات في السنة مما يؤدي إلى
هزيمة فتاة
عندما تكون هناك طرق زراعية حديثة
للماشية والأشياء التي  أعتقد أننا سنتجاوزها في النهاية،
طالما أننا
نحاول الحفاظ عليها ومن
ثم
التأكد من أننا
سنستمر في ثقافتها، فأنا
أفهم أن هناك تحديات في
العالم الحديث وحقيقة أن
التكنولوجيا الجديدة ستجعل حياة الآخرين
أسهل.  ولكن إذا جلبنا لهم هذه التكنولوجيا
ومن ثم تمكنا من العيش
بشكل مريح حيث هم ثم
تمكنا من رفع الأذى بالطريقة التي
هم بها، فأعتقد أنهم سيكونون قادرين على
الاستمرار في عيش حياتهم كما كانت من
قبل،
لذا فهم كذلك.  نحن نصنع اللباد الذي نستخدمه
في تروسنا،
وهذا في الواقع يجعل الأمر أكثر
صرامة،
هل تريد تجربته
بحيث يتم تسطيح الصوف ثم
إنها عملية صنع اللباد نفسه
[موسيقى]
كم من الناس ما زالوا يفعلون هذا
يعني أننا لا نزال نسمع أن
عائلاتهم تفعل ذلك، وهذه هي الطريقة التي تبني بها
الثقافة، وكيف تبني مجتمعك،
نعم
هاهاها [
موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]